البدايه اذا من الاراضي الفلسطينيه والخبر
العاجل حيث اكلت مصادر اسرائيليه ان جنود
الاحتلال قتلوا رميا بالرصاص سائق سياره
فلسطينيه بعد تنفيذه عمليه دهس استهدفت
عددا من الجنود الاسرائيليين عندما مدخل
بلده بيت امر شمال مدينه الخليل بالضفه
الغربيه المحتله
وافادت وسائل اعلاما اسرائيليه ان ثلاثه
جنود اصيب بجروح جراء تعرضهم للدهس بينما
اكرت القناه الاسرائيليه الثانيه عشره ان
الجنود قد قتلوا سائق السياره
من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
العمري بيت امر حدثت فيها حوادث من قبل
تفاصيل ما جرى في هذه الليله وان كانت له
علاقه او سياق يتعلق بحوادث من قبل في
الخليل
الحادث او العمليه وقعت في المسافه
الممتده بين مفترق مجمع مستوطنات تاجوش
عطشون ومدخل بلده بيت امر بين بيت لحم
والخليل في جنوب الضفه الغربيه وقد حصلت
في الفتره التي كان فيها الفلسطينيون على
موائد الافطار لهذا اليوم المعلومات
المتوفره لذلك هي من مصادر الجيش
الاسرائيلي وكذلك المستوطنين وتؤكد بان
ثلاثه من الجنود اصيبوا قال الاسعاف للصيد
الاثنين منهم في حاله الخطر ومصادر الجيش
والمستوطنين ايضا تؤكد بان النيران اطلقت
على سائق السياره الذي قام بدهسهم بينما
كانوا يترجلون على
بجانب طريق هناك وقد استشهد سائق هذه
السياره لم تتضح بعد تفاصيل حول هويته او
مسقط راسه المصادر الفلسطينيه حتى الان
معلوماتها تاتي ايضا من الجانب الاسرائيلي
مصادر الاحتلال والجيش الاسرائيلي
والمستوطنين المنطقه الان مغلقه بالكامل
وفعلا هذه المنطقه شهدت الكثير من اعمال
المقاومه والصدامات مع القوات الاحتلال
والمستوطنين هي مقتظه بالمستوطنات بشكل
كبير والمستوطنون هناك منفلتون الى حد
بعيد
وقوات الاحتلال تتواجد فيها في مسافات
قصيره وعلى مداخل البلدات والمخيمات
الفلسطينيه ومفارق الطرق لحمايه حركه
المستوطنين الذين يعيشون في مدينه الخليل
ومحيط مدينه الخليل وجبل الخليل وكذلك في
كل المنطقه الممتده بين بيت لحم والخليل
وهي مقتظه جدا
بالمستوطين هذا ليس بالعمليه الاولى او
المواجهه الاولى وقاعده السلسله قبل سنتين
كانت هناك سلسله من عمليات الطعن والدهس
وعمليه المقاومه الفلسطينيه في هذه
المنطقه التي استهدفت مستوطنين وكذلك
استهدفت جنود الاحتلال حاليا الوضع ان
قوات الاحتلال اغلقت المنطقه بالكامل
ونشرت الكثير من الحواجز مع العلم ان
المعلومات الوارده من اوساطها بانه قد قتل
سائق السياره بنيران جنود الاحتلال الذين
قاموا باطلاق النيران عليه بعد ان دهس
ثلاثه منهم حسب المصادر الاسرائيليه
بالطبع